the people on reddit they were not
socialists they were not
antifa they were not the dsa
they were the kinds of people who voted
for donald trump
and what the left believes is that's
just neo-nazis and white supremacists or
something but
it's not it's not it's it's people
of all levels of education and all
levels of whatever everything else
who realize that something about this
system is
rigged i know you're not allowed to use
that word when you discuss
elections or when you discuss the
administrative state or when you discuss
the financial establishment
but it just looks rigged i'll give you
give you an example
of this different set of rules for the
liberal elite we talked yesterday
briefly on the show about how
some dude on twitter i think he's 34
years old
so at the time he was if they somewhere
in his 30s somewhere i think at the time
he was in his 20s
during 2015 2016 he had an anonymous
twitter account which was ricky vaughn
and it was very politically incorrect
and very offensive and you say all these
mean things he was just posting memes
and everything
he might go to prison for 10 years
because he posted a meme
which said hey if you're a democrat text
your vote
to this number and you can text your
vote and
then you don't need to worry about
voting and it's an old joke people have
done it for years it's the same joke as
saying
if you're a republican vote tuesday if
you're a democrat vote thursday right
and then you miss the vote
they're threatening him with 10 years in
prison for posting that meme meanwhile
a blue check mark on twitter someone
with the establishment
seal right somehow some of us
conservatives still
have kept it for now i don't know i
still have my blue check mark probably
maybe not after this episode i will
this woman christina wong who's some
comedian got the blue check
she posts the same
exact joke hey everybody this is
christina wong
and uh i'm coming out i'm a trump
supporter
and i just want to remind all my fellow
chinese-americans for trump
people of color for trump to vote vote
for trump
on wednesday november 9th really
important day we're going to show this
country
who's boss and that's our man donald
trump so don't forget to vote donald
trump
on november 9th
old joke right vote vote for trump the
day after the election i've made this
joke i was actually kicked off of
facebook for 24 hours on election day
for making this joke
five years ago four years ago
she also in her tweet about this wrote
uh text your vote to whatever the exact
same thing is rikki bond
she is still on twitter she's still out
of prison she's not being investigated
because she's a liberal she did exact
100 exactly the same thing
as the guy behind ricky vaughn but ricky
vaughn is going to go to the can because
there's a different set of rules
for the liberal elite
you